by the way random non-sequitur if
longmire came to you and said we want to
do a movie the longmire movie or a short
new series would you do it
yeah you would
absolutely you loved doing it
i did
who did you love working with on that
show
i loved working with um
a lot of our directors were really
awesome
very
talented very
efficient
chris chulack was um
he did our pilot and a a lot of our
season finales um
our camera department jimmy muro was our
one of our dps
and uh
he
he's like a legend he's like he was like
the original camera steadicam operator
um
and he whenever he directed he was
sometimes he couldn't find words he'd be
like
and i'd be like yes i think i know what
you mean and i think i'm gonna make that
happen uh
but he just had so much passion and he
has such a beautiful eye with the camera
cameron duncan was our other dp who was
incredibly talented as well
and um our crew is so badass uh
and i love working adam bartley's like a
brother to me um he played the ferg and
he and i
not only came from stage and you know
we're both cherubs
different years we just we came we were
cut from the same cloth and it felt
really familiar and fun to be with him
and katie sackoff is a total supporter
rad chick to be on the show
she's been on the show a couple of times
she's she's an awesome awesome person
yeah we're still we're still dear
friends and um i can't believe we had
kids so close together um
and uh
i can't think of anyone that wasn't
awesome lou diamond phillips is a
sweetheart and and so
like eager to do new things and um rob
is just
rob rob is rob robert taylor who was our
sheriff um all the way from australia
he was just authentic as hell you light
up you light up and i said i mentioned
longmire i just that you just did i
don't have to say much you just kind of
open up about wow it sounds like you
would do this in a heartbeat this was
like a family to you
yeah yeah they really were i love them
you